here's what would happen if the earth  was flat the center of gravity on a flat  earth would be right in the middle and  the further you got from the center the  stronger that gravity's pull would be  because of this you'd never be able to  walk to the edge of a flat earth a flat  earth's gravity would also make trees  grow diagonally on most parts of the  earth and objects closer to the edge  would fall sideways instead of falling  down all our rain snow and hail would  fall toward the arctic which would be at  the center of the earth the oceans would  get sucked to the center too forming one  big ocean in the middle flat earth  proponents claim the sun travels in  circles three thousand kilometers above  the flat earth that means there would be  no day and night cycles on a flat earth  no time zones no seasons either so it's  safe to say it's impossible we're living  on a flat earth  but  some people around the globe are still  convinced of this so